it's time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
safe and good home as part of
seniors month lori that's right hi
kendall
you know november is adopt a senior pet
month and in honor
of that nevada's launched a new program
called senior for seniors
where um animals little dogs like shadow
here
a beautiful little dachshund any dogs
ages 10 and up
or rather dogs eight enough and cats 10
and up
will be free to human seniors ages 65
and up
at nevada spca and shadow here
is a 12 year old senior dachshund
that is available for adoption now um
very friendly little boy like we do all
the time at nevada spca we've already
provided all of the medical care
so he's available for adoption he had
some flatter stones removed and some
dental work done
and i think he even had a hernia fix so
he's all fixed up
and ready for a loving new home and as
you can tell he's a very effective robot
he looks like an absolute sweetheart and
what's great is it actually
looks like he's smiling has a little
perma grin on his face
oh he has such a nice personality
kendall he will be
um a very affectionate addition to any
home and from what we can tell he
gets along with everybody again we've
gotten him into good shape from a health
standpoint
he's going to require a special diet so
those bladder stones don't come back
again
and a little medication but for a 12
year old you know little dogs like this
can live for a long time so there's a
lot of life left
in dogs like shadow and again if you're
a senior a human senior age of 65 and up
shadow would be free to you that's
wonderful and there is an additional
challenge in getting these dogs adopted
right those that are
senior dogs no there is kendall
unfortunately the younger pets
in shelters like nevada spca tend to go
quicker
and oftentimes the seniors are much
easier pet to deal with they're calmer
you know they have that maturity and
wisdom that comes with ears and
you know i also want to point out that
we had a very supportive donor nevada
spca come to us
with thoughts on this program and really
thought it would be a good fit for
senior animals and
human seniors and she anonymously
anonymously has donated the money
so we're able to offer this tea today we
certainly thank that
individual for their generosity lori
thank you as always
if you're interested in adopting a pet
go to nevadaspca.org or call them at the
number on your screen 702-873-7722